[Musique]
souvent je pars de courbes jeu je suis à
s'inspirer donc par la nature les
insectes genre de choses donc j'essaie
de tracer des courbes sur une feuille
qui soit assez forte que j'estime assez
forte pour pouvoir envisager d'en faire
à l'avenir une lampe
on pourrait dire que d'amis adresse et
un ébéniste de la lumière
sa matière première c'est le bois il
sait le travail et il a appris toutes
les techniques d'ébénisterie pendant
quatre ans des jo sur ma peau
ébénisterie m'a appris à avoir une
rigueur pour faire des objets qu'ils
soient c'est pas des sculptures c'est
des objets fonctionnels qui vont dans un
intérieur pour une fonction qui qui
doivent être solide stable qui doivent
éclairer de préférence donc en ce moment
là j'ai envie de partir sur sur cette
lan plein ce qui l'intéresse c'est de
laisser aller son imagination avec les
différentes espèces de bois il joue des
couleurs et des contrastes pour créer
des luminaires tout en courbes pour une
lampe il peut utiliser plusieurs
essences donc ici on a du platane du
wing et dufresne du tech du cerisier
pour réaliser là bas jour il découpe des
fines feuilles de placage
il utilise de l'érable un bois clair qui
laisse filtrer la lumière et la
diffusent ce qui est bien dans la
création des langues c'est qu'en fait
c'est un objet qui se transforme on à
l'objet est un éloge est allumée qui
font justement dans l'objet étant ça se
rapprochera plus justement d'un meuble
classique on a le bois tel qu'on a
l'habitude de le voir on peut travailler
la forme comme sur un meuble etc
hop est allumée ça transforme la matière
ça lui donne à la chaleur du bois
dupuis à l'abat jour les courbes sont
douces et les lignes très épurées
c'est précis et minutieux un véritable
travail d'orfèvre
[Musique]